certains disent que l' aventure est au
bout de la rue d'autres vont la chercher
très loin il largue les amarres pour
réaliser le rêve ultime du voyageur
faire un tour du monde nous aussi un
jour on fera un tour du monde comme vous
sympathique à bout vous êtes de vrais
hommes ça plaît aux femmes machine tout
de suite venir avec vous
besoin d'échapper au quotidien envie de
rencontres de nouveaux horizons aller au
bout du monde c'est découvrir les autres
se frotter à leur culture c'est aussi
accepter de prendre des risques
et c'est plutôt bon
tu aimes bien même si ce n'est pas
toujours agréable pour ceux qui n'ont
rien demandé c'est pas mal mais au petit
déj
pas très appétissant
[Musique]
tout plaquer sortir de chez soi et se
rendre utile dans les endroits oubliés
du monde
honorable
partager ma passion de l'athlé en
afrique oui les gars c'est super c'est
comme on l'avait imaginé cantona quand
on a fait le projet
5000 français se lancent chaque année
sur les routes entre eux ils s'appellent
les tourdumondiste alors nous aussi nous
sommes partis faire le tour du monde à
la recherche de ces voyageurs sans
frontières nous avons croisé la famille
vasse un couple et leurs trois enfants
partis prendre le pouls de la terre
pendant un an delphine et maxime 2
idéaliste engagée dans un tour du monde
humanitaire et puis thierry et killian
de grands rêveurs qui se sont lancé un
défi fou marché pendant cinq ans autour
de la planète
aujourd'hui chacun veut son tour ce
n'est pas seulement un voyage ce n'est
surtout pas du tourisme c'est une
aventure très sérieuse qui doit avoir du
sens
[Musique]
il nous a fallu aller loin pour
retrouver la famille vasse
au bout de sept mois de voyage après
avoir traversé l'amérique du sud
l'australie et la chine les voici au
beau milieu des steppes d'asie centrale
la famille un drôle de rendez vous
il faut faire très attention à l'autre
la position des pieds qu'est ce qu'il
faut à quoi il faut veiller
[Musique]
s'il répète les codes de bonne conduite
local c'est parce qu'ils vont partager
pendant deux semaines le quotidien d'une
famille nomades de mongolie une
immersion totale pour frédéric vanessa
et leurs trois enfants le plus jeune à
natal à trois ans elliott 11 et jules 8
ans une nouvelle expérience à temps les
globe-trotters on va vivre sans
électricité sans douche et c'est
intéressant et ses bras enjambera envie
de me confronter à celles de voir
comment les enfants réagissent
mais non
un guide les a mis en relation avec
cette famille qui a rarement l'occasion
de voir des étrangers
vous montrer et vous n'oubliez pas pris
barrière de la langue et des cultures
oblige les deux familles se font face
intimidé
le contact commence par une découverte
culinaire site fromage de quoi
franchement je n'y a qu'un
[Musique]
c'est le
le lot et l'eau où exactement il y en a
beaucoup de l'eau vous avez le vent et
le soleil contre vous plus la france ça
fait beaucoup mais vous avez des bottes
pas nous
pour briser la glace frédéric propose
une partie de foot sur ses plateaux à
2500 mètres d'altitude
quand mr
[Musique]
et en retour les hommes de la famille
mongole ils ont réservé une surprise
l'achat invités ils ont tué un mouton
quand il ya un invité comme élise de
marque dans la famille dans son si
famille française qui vient tous a passé
deux semaines avec là ça sera la viande
de d2 sport éventuel moutons des
protéines être arrivé ça servira à
nourrir et la famille et nous pour 15
jours on va essayer une habitation peut
pas refuser
[Musique]
pour ces citadins chacune de leurs
étapes est une aventure fans et ça
travaille dans un journal à nantes
frédéric et directeur de communication
ils ont tous deux pris une année
sabbatique pour se retrouver dans des
endroits comme celui ci les mains
plongées dans les entrailles d'un mouton
[Musique]
on va utiliser qu'on va manger
vrai que l'intestin c'est très long si
je parlais sa langue je pourrais lui
expliquer comment faire mais c'est bien
qu'elle nous aide contente pas être une
femme m'a chauve que les les rôles sont
toujours très bien à part ça j'ai été
invité à tuer le bouton je peux
maintenant qu'il est tendu là il a été
super mais
l'ambiance
c'est comme cela qu'ils voyagent depuis
sept mois chez l'habitant sous la tente
dans de petites auberges ils fuient les
circuits touristiques
les vases ont mis deux ans à préparer
leur tour du monde ils ont créé de
toutes pièces ce voyage à travers le
monde pour éveiller la conscience de
leurs enfants un itinéraire en dix
étapes pour comprendre la planète et ses
enjeux
ferme
en un an ils auront vous les statues
moai de l'île de pâques au large du
chili l'occasion d'étudier des raisons
de la disparition des civilisations en
argentine ils ont frôlé des bananes
australe du pacifique victimes de la
pollution de la mer elles sont en voie
d'extinction
en inde ils ont passé plusieurs jours
dans un village pour comprendre des
problèmes d'accès à l'eau potable
7 oh c'est pas boire les enfants filmés
par leurs pairs réalise de courts
reportages qu'ils envoient régulièrement
aux élèves de leur classe pour laisser
une trace du style
[Musique]
le lendemain matin dans la steppe
mongole la température a chuté de 20
degrés
malgré l'air glacial leva sa compagne
les nomades le troisième jour du mois de
juin il faut couper la crinière des
cheveux quelle que soit la météo ont des
gars venaient voir comment il fait ça
c'est le luxe d tourdumondiste prendre
le temps être là où personne ne va les
vastes veulent voir et participer vivre
comme ceux qui les accueillent et la
curiosité s'éveille des deux côtés
je me demande à quoi ressemble leur pays
quand ils vendent les crinières ça leur
rapporte beaucoup pas beaucoup pas
vraiment beaucoup
deux mille cinq cents
le kilo
frédéric et vanessa n'épargne rien à
leurs enfants même ces moments rude
ils disent qu'ils veulent les confronter
à une autre réalité loin de ce qu'ils
ont connu jusqu'à présent comme de vivre
sans électricité et sans robinet d'eau
chaude
[Musique]
jamais un champion comme ça en fait avec
de l'oublier luigi sur le sur le poil
ça fait tellement du bien et j'ai envie
d'en faire un autre
[Musique]
corvée d'eau de bois tous les membres de
la famille seront mises à contribution
durant ce séjour ambiance colonie de
vacances à but éducatif
partager avec une famille une vie simple
des gestes simples je crois que c'était
important que les enfants comprennent ça
ça fait partie des valeurs qu'on voulait
leur transmettre est ce que je trouve
intéressant c'est qu'en plus ce sont des
valeurs qui devraient être universels
c'est ça qui est intéressant pour nous
et pour eux j'espère
un vaste programme nous les laissons la
plongée dans un autre temps dans une
ambiance polaire et les retrouverons
quelques semaines plus tard sous
d'autres tropiques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les nouveaux tourdumondiste ne partent
pas sur un coup de tête ils veulent que
leur voyage soit unique est utile tout
de suite sur les routes du nord du chili
à la frontière du pérou nous avons
retrouvé delphine et maxime eux ont
quitté leur travail en pleine crise elle
dans le marketing lui dans le sport pour
partir ils ont planché pendant trois ans
sur leurs voyages aussi sérieusement que
sur un projet professionnel pour nous
c'était rencontrer partager créer des
liens avec les gens qu'on allait voir et
apporter ce qu'on pouvait apporter on se
dira peut-être qu'on sait pas faire
grand chose avec nos - ou techniquement
en tout cas vraiment je parle pour moi
mais on a acquis une acquis des choses
au travers de nos études
de ce qu'on a pu faire en france et on
voulait se servir de ça pour la porter
voilà des gens qu'on a rencontrés c'est
pour ça qu'on a créé notre association
avec laquelle on a réussi à récolter des
dons travers différents événements et
aujourd'hui on se sert de l'argent pour
aller aider des associations qu'on a
choisi qu'on va rencontrer durant un
voyage
un tour du monde solidaire de
l'humanitaire à petite échelle comme ici
à roy bean à une oasis perdu dans le
désert de l'atacama l'un des plus arides
au monde le village détruit par un
tremblement de terre il ya cinq ans vit
en autarcie maxime et delphine sont
venus jusqu'ici pour se retrouver dans
ce réduit en parpaings et se pencher sur
le cas de cette turbine elle fournit
l'électricité du village est en panne et
vous connaissez quelqu'un qui pourrait
la réparer ah non ça c'est pas le
problème mais il nous faut de l'argent
pour acheter les pièces et les câbles et
on n'a pas les moyens dans le village
delphine et maxime ne sont passés par
aucune agence pour déterminer leur
itinéraire en deux ans ils ont
sélectionné quinze projets à travers le
monde quinze destinations dans des
continents différents des endroits où il
pouvait être utile à chaque fois il
reste quelques semaines pour évaluer les
besoins et vivre en immersion
jouer les bons samaritains leur permet
surtout de sortir des sentiers battus
oui c'est mieux avec ce couteau comme sa
coupe vers la pointe vers le bas
c'est un moment de partage avec les gens
et puis c'est aider dans le quotidien
des gens et c'est comme ça qu'on s'en
sert aussi et on gagne la confiance des
gens quoi même si pour l'instant on
n'est pas très efficace de moi je pense
trop l'australien
en six mois deux tours du monde ils
n'auront pas pris une seule journée de
vraies vacances le farniente ne fait pas
partie de leur voyage distille ici ils
soutiennent un projet d'écotourisme
ils vont donner entre 500 à 1000 euros
une partie des dons récoltés par leur
association
c'est difficile de faire ses confitures
mais nous ce qu'on veut c'est montrer
que ça vient d'un village avec un logo
qu'on aurait inventé comme ça on les
voit vrai avec notre marque
ils ont 26 mille euros pour vivre leurs
années de voyage le fruit de leur
économie il leur faut donc se loger
gratuitement en échange de leur art ce
village ils dormiront dans une remise un
brin précaire et c'est ce qu'ils aiment
un tour du monde des hôtels n'aurait
pour eux aucun sens la débrouille fait
partie du voyage
en fait on est accueilli de la même
manière que les gens vivent leur vie ici
on en n'est pas traité différemment
parce qu'on vient aider au parce que le
touriste français et du coup on est
logés dans les mêmes conditions de vie
que les personnes d'ici et ça ça nous
fait plaisir c'était ça notre notre
notion de voyage n'en de de partager
vraiment la vie des gens
[Musique]
le soir l'ambiance est studieuse il leur
faut préparer la suite du périple après
le chili ils s'envoleront pour
l'australie puis l'afrique du sud où ils
nous ont donné rendez vous deux mois
plus tard
[Applaudissements]
s'il en est d'autres qui ont fait de la
rencontre leur religion c'est sans doute
ces deux marcheurs pour rien au monde
ils n'accepteraient de monter dans un
bus ou une voiture ils sont partis à 12
il ya deux ans ils ne sont plus que deux
très vite il ya eu des divergences de
points de vue au niveau de l'équipe et
il y en a qui voulaient stopper beaucoup
et donc il voulait surtout marché de fil
en aiguille mon 9 constitué de deux
grandes écoles et finalement vous vous
êtes les deux qui restent l'équipe
on essaye de faire le tour du monde
juste en marchant donc ça peut paraître
un peu sectaire certaines pas prendre la
voiture tandis pendant dix mètres mais
c'est un jeu aussi et puis c'est on a
marché jusqu'ici on le fait tout en
marchant donc si on commence à prendre
la moitié des transports course à perdre
sa valeur
les deux irréductibles s'apprête à
traverser le kazakhstan une ancienne
république soviétique coincée entre la
russie et la chine en deux ans ils ont
parcouru six mille kilomètres
e
c'est thierry à gauche qui a eu cette
idée marché cinq ans autour du monde il
a posté une annonce sur internet et
killian l'a rejoint il était ingénieur
et a tout lâché
comprend
eux n'ont pas préparé leur voyage
pendant des années son parti un beau
jour de mai 2008 avec l' envie de
traverser le monde en marchant sans
prendre ni l'avion ni l'autre un juste
des cargos quand il le faut ils ont pris
la route à partir de valence dans la
drôme avec chacun 7000 euros en poche
assez pour tenir selon leurs critères
cinq ans
bonjour alors quand ils font les courses
toute équité au centime près on voudrait
4 pin vous voulez lequel parce que j'en
ai plein
le moins cher ils se nourrissent de peu
du pain et du fromage essentiellement
on a fait les économies avant est
produit avec ses économies pour
atteindre - l'australie où là on pourra
travailler donc il faut qu'on vive tous
les jours avec qui on a calculé en gros
notre budget c'est 2 euros par jour
[Musique]
pour l'instant ça va l'europe c'est un
peu chaud
ici depuis la turquie globalement sont
réceptifs
huit mois en turquie 3 en géorgie un an
en europe le temps pour eux un autre
sens
ils veulent le prendre le temps pour se
frotter aux autochtones distille sans
prévoir juste en se laissant guider par
les rencontres quand ils partent le
matin ils ne savent jamais où ils
dormiront des mots que tu connaissais
pas
compris ce soir il s'arrête à l'épicerie
du village en quête d'un emplacement de
planter leur tente et rebondit chercher
sublime avec
nous dormir
tentes matelas
dormir possible spat
vous avez une tente
ouais on va pouvoir vous arranger ça
mais moi j'ai un chien il est très
méchant
il faut faire attention parce que sinon
ils comptent la gorge
on peut planter la tente mais des chiens
mais ils vont attaché le chien parce que
voilà
c'est méchant ça bac à
[Rires]
bac a
encore
fait mieux après deux ans de voyage ils
ont constaté qu'ils étaient souvent bien
accueillis aux hôtes de passage leur
donne vite confiance et leur offre gîte
et couvert
si j'avais su j'aurais pu préparer
quelque chose de mieux j'aurais tué un
mouton et cuisiner un bon ragoût marcoux
je crois
toujours
d'ailleurs je parte
des moments comme celui ci ils en vivent
tous les jours une récompense aux
longues heures de marche
c'est une succession d'opportunités
absolument inouïe on peut vraiment pas
vivre ce genre de chose en restant chez
soi donc forcément ça nous donne envie
de toujours en avoir plus que je pense
que j'ai vraiment changé depuis le début
de ce voyage j'ai appris à avoir de pas
avoir peur de l'inconnu peur des autres
donc
confiance en l'humanité on retrouve
retrouver foi en la bonté humaine
[Applaudissements]
c'est au nord du vietnam à hanoi que
nous retrouvons la famille vasse comme à
chacune de leurs étapes ils cherchent un
logement bon marché
mincir n'a pas relâché sa tournée
ils ont mis 38 euros d'économies dans ce
voyage grâce aux forfaits tour du monde
des compagnies aériennes autour de 2000
euros par personne pour dix étapes le
budget transport n'est pas le plus
important c'est le quotidien qu'il faut
gérer 100 euros par jour pour toute la
famille alors ces sacs à dos transports
en commun et petites auberges et une
seule chambre pour 5
1 et 3 refuge où les enfants font leurs
devoirs et diodes prend ses cours de 6e
par correspondance jules est en ce2
il leur faut travailler quatre heures
par jour c'était l'appréhension des
parents comment les enfants sains et ils
vivre cette parenthèse dans leur
scolarité vanessa s'est improvisé
maîtresse d'école une école nomade ils
ont appris à travailler dans n'importe
quelle condition mais vraiment n'importe
quel point à travailler dans le bus ont
travaillé dans le train dans la gare qui
dans les gares routières sur des tables
dans des cafés ou un trail et en
australie dans un camping où il faisait
40 degrés on avait réussi à 3 1 points
en mai et en fait ils se sont adaptés
quoi ça fait partie du jeu ils savent
que c'est comme ça
les enfants suivent mais ils ont aussi
leurs moments de lassitude
ça fait quoi d'être à l'école avec ses
frères plutôt qu'à ses copains et ça
c'est pas vraiment drôle monsieur
bah des fois avec une frères des fois
j'ai envie de lâcher un peu
et donc elles varient la fin fut en plus
sur un peu tout seul pour travailler et
je préfère avec mes copains
[Musique]
pour suivre la scolarité des enfants
n'était pas le seul défi il fallait
aussi gérer la distance et le manque
une fois par semaine la famille au grand
complet se réunit devant l'ordinateur
pour appeler les proches
grâce aux communications gratuites via
internet rien ne paraît insurmontable ce
même l'inquiétude des grands parents
avec qui on était franchement très
active et au fur et à mesure on
s'aperçoit que ils sont tellement
heureux au temple mon fils sa
belle-fille les trois enfants que pour
eux c'est vide et c'est un bonheur de
les voir réussir une expérience pareille
est-ce que je vous en raconter
l'histoire assouplies
et à la première phase du voyage ou
l'absence des proches est très forte et
même peut être difficile et qu'il ya
après une fois qu'on a passé ce cap on
réussit à vivre et à se sentir bien sans
que ce manque soit douloureux
parfois des amis viennent les rejoindre
là où ils se trouvent
ils sont comme des bouées auquel
s'accrochaient quelques jours dans cette
vie sans anna
à hanoi ils ont rendez vous avec un de
leurs vieux copain de nantes c'est la
première visite de france depuis quatre
mois
[Musique]
l'excitation est à son comble au la
regarde
et la maîtresse à penser
hervé arrive les bras chargés de cadeaux
de la part de la famille des amis des
copains de classe les visiteurs ont un
surnom les enfants les appels et mulets
ce qui transforme tout ce qu'ils
pourront nous
encore perdu
à erbil en fait partie
nous a remis un cadeau
cadeaux qu'à noël quoi
sentant mieux
c'est émouvant prête je m'attendais pas
à ça je crois que ça va être bon
moi ouais ouais ouais moi touchant quoi
là c'est vraiment je sens que c'est la
salle la portance quoi vraiment pour par
la tôle pour jules pour elliott pour les
parents
[Musique]
pour remercier leurs amies les vaches
ont consenti à se laisser aller à une
escapade touristique au nord d'hanoï
dans la très fameuse baie d'halong un
moment rare dans leur voyage les mêmes
là ils ne veulent pas faire comme
n'importe quel touriste
la baie d'ha long on a trouvé je crois
un système qui est pas mal on est un
bateau que nous avons trop grand pour
nous on est tout seul on est tout seul
et ça fait quand même beaucoup de bien
de se dire qu'on va passer une journée à
peu près peinard
moi j'aime bien
la baie d'halong des centaines de piton
rocheux plantés dans les eaux du golfe
du tonkin une des merveilles du monde
à l'avant de la jonque la famille se
livrent un drôle d'exercice
ils sont en train de faire ce qu'ils
appellent leur top 15 j solaire
- 15e gmi terre de feu
et moi 15e j'aime ici l'eau et les
quinze moment qu'ils ont préféré depuis
le début de leur tour du monde
glaciers de patagonie tortues marines en
australie steppes mongoles
5e jet le tortueux
une conversation familial peu banal
depuis un moment tout ça c'est
extraordinaire j'ai trop aimé à
pratiquement 100 mètres du lit mais
c'est incomparable c'est à vous si
vraiment c'est super d'être premier
j'ai hâte x j'ai les moai mon premier
j'ai les baleines de valdés
un mois avant la fin de leur tour du
monde c'est déjà l'heure des premiers
bilans
pour eux leur aventure est une réussite
pas de soucis majeurs des enfants qui
ont suivi et aimé ils disent s'être
offert des souvenirs en partage
vanessa et moi on avait tous les deux
des métiers
qui nous prenait beaucoup de temps
qui en prendront
encore beaucoup après quand rencontrera
donc c'est une vraie pause en famille
moi j'ai la première grande nouvelle
c'est que je crois que j'ai redécouvert
mes trois garçons et la sensation de ne
plus pouvoir tricher entre nous donc ça
a changé déjà ça c'est d'abord cinq
personnes d'une même famille qui se
connaissent mieux
et on a maintenant
cette envie de mesurer est ce que nos
enfants maintenant ont déjà saisi tout
ce qu'il fallait saisir de cette
expérience autour du monde
on le saura pas maintenant on le saura
peut-être beaucoup plus tard eux le
seront beaucoup plus tard et on sera je
pense fier de ça quand on sera rentré
et voudra quand tu
es bon tu aimeras encore
là
nous retrouvons les marcheurs il ne
marche plus il chante du joe dassin au
beau milieu d'un mariage kazakh
c'est très intéressant depuis que nous
les avions quittés un mois auparavant
ils ont parcouru 600 kilomètres
il faut dire qu'il s'arrête partout
comme dans cette fête de village croisé
par hasard
le roi
un repas de roi qui sera arrosé de votre
cas locales comme il se doit leurs
façons de voyager et des quelques mots
de casaque qu'ils ont appris leur ouvre
toutes les portes
ah
ils dansent vraiment bien ah oui savent
s'amuser eux ils peuvent rester le temps
qu'ils veulent
y'a un truc qui se passe on s'arrête le
temps qu'il faut pour apprécier pour
partager vraiment à fond
on est en retard c'est relatif ceux
relatifs aux retards fait on est parti
depuis deux ans et on a un an de retard
sur le planning prévisionnel
normalement devrait-on devrait être en
inde ou en thaïlande actuellement on est
à 6000 km de la maison on devrait être à
12000 un gros
dans cette vie hors du temps les
journées se suivent et ne se ressemblent
jamais malgré tout il faut partir
la
france et le kazakhstan sont des amis
pour la vie tombée
près ce village un long désert les
attend
ça fait deux mètres tu t'arrêtes bon va
pas être copain avec
temps face 3000 nommera
un villageois leur a prêté un chameau
pour quelques kilomètres il voulait les
aider et soulager du poids de leur sac à
dos le temps d'atteindre les portes du
désert
[Musique]
m
thierry et killian aurais tu aimé garder
leurs montures mais cela leur aurait
coûté 2000 euros le prix d'un an et demi
de marche
[Musique]
muni d'une simple boussole et de
quelques litres d'eau il se lance en
direction de la chine dans la traversée
du désert de kyzylkoum l'un des plus
grands au monde
ils savent que durant ce mois de marche
ils pourront rester plusieurs jours sans
croiser âme qui vive
cinq heures plus tard ils sont exténués
on dirais pas que c'est aussi grand en
fait j'ai pas si c'est le sel qu'il faut
c'est assez différent
et puis c'est la vase on s'enfonce à
moitié étaient des chaussures sa monnaie
et préparer aux tours du but tellement
pas tellement mois en partant je faisais
sans qu'ils vont donc faire mesure des
mois on sera demain c'est un peu comme
tout quoi j'ai perdu quelque chose comme
tranquille où la suite et vu que mon sac
le soir ils bivouac
mais pourquoi s'acharne-t-il ans si
vous avez l'impression d'être en fuite
ont en quelque sorte fat apparemment une
impression mais quand on analyse la
chose
non mais on s'est échappé de la morosité
morosité la société global quoi et tout
ce qui est ses problèmes économiques etc
on pourrait dire sois là pour moi j'ai
pas l'impression que c'est une fuite
c'est plutôt une recherche et une
recherche de quelque chose d'autre d'un
au système d'autres valeurs plutôt que
notre société avec accumulé des biens
construire accumulé des biens
principalement et recherche d'autres
choses de rapports humains plus simple
nous les avons laissés là au milieu du
désert kazakh nous étions un peu
inquiets et puis nous avons eu des
nouvelles de un mois plus tard heureux
d'avoir franchi les steppes arides il se
préparait à rejoindre la chine pour un
don
[Applaudissements]
dernière étape pour maximiser le fim
dans leur tour du monde solidaire
l'afrique du sud
quand nous les retrouvons à l'aéroport
de johannesbourg ils viennent de passer
trois semaines en australie
à peine arrivés ils ne vont pas
s'attarder et visiter la ville le
premier endroit qu'ils verront c'est ce
centre commercial
ils vont y acheter des chaussures de
sport les shorts pour une vingtaine de
jeunes coureurs d'une communauté
sud-africaine c'est leur dernière bonne
action ça me fait bizarre de rentrer
dans le vif du sujet là c'est un projet
qu'on a préparé qu'on a on a monté des
dossiers au début ce teckel décrit
ensuite on est parti en voyage là ça se
concrétise vraiment dans l'espace leur
fera plaisir on a hâte de voir leurs
réactions demain assez content
la destination finale leur voyage en
afrique du sud la voici du parc kruger
d'une des grandes réserves naturelles de
la région ils ne verront rien non plus
après six heures de route depuis
johannesburg il s'arrête au bord d'un
terrain de sport où ils sont attendus
avec impatience
ces vins genze athlètes participent aux
compétitions de la région ça va les gars
pas trop froid ce matin tous vivent dans
des camps en chip des bidonvilles sud
africain alors lui il pour le
semi-marathon et lui aussi
est là c'est mon coureur le plus rapide
qu'elle me kaloum pineau sur 100 m et
200 m et en plus ils courent pieds nus
c'est très dur mais n'empêche que c'est
le pur atteint 10 aux fastes
[Musique]
maxime ancien champion de france
d'athlétisme va rester trois semaines
ici pour vivre avec eux et les entraîner
chaque jour avant leur prochaine
compétition
[Musique]
à
servat maxime vous êtes content
ouais
cela plaide encore plus longtemps et
puis bah on a partagé blanc de sourire
pendant la course et où c'était sympa
[Rires]
il a un bon rythme et un beau style
donc là on va donner une gourde un short
à chacun et on va donner une paire de
chaussures mais ça c'est juste un début
quoi on espère pouvoir fournir plus dans
les mois à venir mais
c'est comme cela qu'ils avaient imaginé
leur voyage un tour du monde pour une
première prise de contact
alors ça c'est des chaussures de
champion
saturé gagner plein de médailles tu
crois tu peux courir plus vite que moi
maintenant moi je crois pas
et une suite après leur retour en france
ça tu sais à quoi ça sert c'est pour
mettre de l'eau et c'est très important
de boire pendant que du court
ils veulent que cette aide se
poursuivent
sous forme de don ils enverront
directement à ceux auxquels ils font
confiance
à l'est et répétez après moi nous sommes
le club des pieds libre
là maintenant on a un vrai nom pour
notre club plus rien ne pourra nous
arrêter
à part moi non moi je peux t'arrêter
non même toit
[Rires]
on va tout gagner
[Musique]
témoin éclairé de la réalité du monde
acteur passionné de son changement
idéaliste pas si naïf que cela ils ont
les pieds sur terre et finalement
parviennent à leurs fins les nouveaux
tourdumondiste veulent redonner du sens
au voyage
[Musique]
thor